Traductor: Analia Padin
Revisor: Frank Zegarra
En 1849, en el sitio de la antigua ciudad
de Nínive en el norte de Irak,
un equipo de arqueólogos
examinaba unas ruinas polvorientas
esperando encontrar algo que probara
la veracidad de las historias bíblicas.
En cambio,
encontraron una de las bibliotecas
más antiguas del mundo.
Inscripta en tablillas
de arcilla deteriorada,
se encontraba una historia
de 4000 años de antigüedad tan apasionante
que la primera persona que las tradujo
empezó a desvestirse de la emoción.
La llamada Epopeya de Gilgamesh,
comienza con Gilgamesh,
rey de la ciudad de Uruk,
que se presentaba sin invitación
en las bodas para dormir con la novia
antes de que pudiera hacerlo su esposo.
Para calmar a Gilgamesh, la diosa Aruru
le creó un rival llamado Enkidu.
Enkidu vivía fuera
de los muros de la ciudad,
donde reinaba el caos
y merodeaban animales salvajes,
invasores y espíritus malignos.
Cuando una de las sacerdotisas
de la diosa Ishtar sedujo a Enkidu,
los animales salvajes lo rechazaron
entonces Enkidu se aventuró a la ciudad.
Allí encontró a Gilgamesh
haciendo lo de siempre.
Enkidu intervino para detenerlo.
El combate entre los dos fue muy parejo
y lucharon por las calles de la ciudad
hasta que Gilgamesh ganó por un pelo.
A partir de ese momento,
fueron inseparables.
Con su nuevo amigo, Gilgamesh
abandonó su interés por las novias de Uruk
y se concentró en demostrar
su fuerza en el combate.
Partieron para asesinar a Humbaba,
una criatura de mil caras
que custodiaba el Bosque de los Cedros.
Lo rastrearon y le hicieron una emboscada.
Acorralado, Humbaba suplicó por su vida
y luego los maldijo mientras Gilgamesh
daba el último golpe.
De vuelta en Uruk, la diosa Ishtar
le declaró su amor a Gilgamesh.
Sabiendo que la diosa solía perder interés
y maldecir a sus viejos amantes,
Gilgamesh rechazó sus avances.
En represalia, Ishtar
liberó al Toro del Cielo
para que destruyera las cosechas
y matara gente en Uruk.
Cuando Gilgamesh y Enkidu
mataron al Toro en defensa de la ciudad,
los dioses mataron a Enkidu.
Entró en la “casa del polvo”,
el oscuro inframundo de la Mesopotamia
donde los espíritus de los muertos
se arrodillaban eternamente
comiendo tierra y bebiendo piedras.
Afligido por la muerte de Enkidu
y aterrado de correr la misma suerte,
Gilgamesh emprendió el rumbo
más allá de las montañas cósmicas
en busca de la inmortalidad.
Encontró hombres escorpiones
y árboles de piedras preciosas,
pasó por debajo de las montañas
y corrió más rápido que el sol,
hasta que finalmente
llegó al fin del mundo,
donde encontró una taberna.
La tabernera, una diosa llamada Shiduri,
le imploró a Gilgamesh
que abandonara su búsqueda.
Le dijo que todos los mortales
estaban destinados a morir,
pero que debía disfrutar de su vida
hasta que le llegara la muerte.
Pero Gilgamesh no quiso darse por vencido.
A regañadientes, Shiduri le indicó
cómo cruzar las Aguas de la Muerte
para encontrarse con Utanapishti,
el hombre inmortal.
Los dioses le habían concedido
la inmortalidad a Utanapishti
luego de un gran diluvio
durante el cual había construido un arca,
cargado dos animales de cada especie
y desembarcado en el pico de una montaña.
Utanapishti también alentó a Gilgamesh
a aceptar que la muerte
llegaba para todos.
Pero Gilgamesh insistió.
Utanapishti le dijo entonces
que, si conseguía vencer el sueño,
tal vez los dioses
le concederían la inmortalidad.
Gilgamesh trató de mantenerse despierto
durante siete días,
pero se quedó dormido inmediatamente.
Utanapishti le dijo de una planta mágica
que crecía en el fondo del océano
y otorgaba la eterna juventud.
Si bien Gilgamesh
pudo encontrar la planta,
una serpiente se la robó
en el camino de regreso a casa.
Pero, cuando Gilgamesh
volvió a ver su hermosa ciudad,
hizo las paces con su mortalidad
y juró pasar el resto de su vida
haciendo grandes logros.
Escribió su historia
en una tablilla de lapislázuli
y la enterró debajo
de las murallas de la ciudad
para que futuras generaciones
la encontraran y aprendieran de ella.
Las tablillas encontradas en Nínive
pertenecían a la biblioteca
del rey asirio Asurbanipal.
Si bien la historia es un mito, Gilgamesh
fue probablemente un rey de Uruk.
Las distintas versiones de esta historia
datan del año 2000 a. C. o incluso antes,
pero aún están presentes
en la literatura de nuestros días.